World War I shaped our world
in many, many, many ways.
And it's important to realize
it wasn't that long ago.
It was not even 100 years ago.
But it was really the end of
the more traditional empires.
It was the end of kingdoms.
It really reshaped much
of the globe much more
around states defined by nations
rather than states defined
by monarchies or states
defined by empires.
And it was also the first war
where technology, or I would
say modern technology--
technology has always
played a major role in wars.
In fact, wars have been a
catalyst for technology often.
But it was the
first time that much
of what we consider to
be modern technology
played a huge role in the
actual carrying out of the war.
And to a large
degree, this is what
made the war so much
bloodier, and one
could argue, even
more protracted.
So here I have a
bunch of pictures
of the various technologies
used in World War I.
Here in this picture you have
a machine gun, which obviously
allows you to indiscriminately
mow down folks.
These guys, it looks
like they might
be in some type of a trench.
And so you could
imagine that combination
if viewed from above.
So let's say that
this is a trench.
This is a trench
right over here.
We're looking from above.
So there's some people
sitting in the trench.
A couple of these folks
have machine guns.
The rest of the guys just
have rifles over here.
If you wanted to
storm this trench,
you'd be in a bad situation.
The guy with the
machine gun essentially
could just mow people down.
They also tended
to use barbed wire.
Barbed wire wasn't
invented in World War
I. It was invented many
decades before in the 1800s.
But that would make it
very hard for someone
to cross this period.
They would get stuck in it.
At which point these guys in
the trench could shoot him down.
And it would be very hard to
shoot the guys in the trench.
So it also, other than
making it very deadly,
it gave all the
advantages to the defense.
So any time someone
wanted to gain ground,
especially in one of the fronts
where trench warfare was being
used, it was a hugely,
hugely, hugely bloody affair.
The other technology
that came into mainstream
use in World War I
was the use of gas,
and in particular poison gas.
And as you see these
gentleman right over here,
they're wearing gas
masks because they're
afraid that their opponent
is going to use poison gas.
And the benefit of
gas in particular
is let's say you have an
artillery shell that you throw
over and it doesn't hit anybody.
But then it starts
releasing a canister
of-- let me do that
in a different color--
it starts releasing
a canister of gas.
So the gas I've drawn
in this purplish color.
And so it doesn't have
to be a direct hit.
It can just linger there
and infect that trench.
And it'll affect everyone there.
And gas warfare was--
actually, the Germans
weren't first to use
just gas warfare.
But they were the first
to use very lethal, what
we would call poison, gas.
And in particular in 1915,
they used chlorine gas.
So let me write that down.
Chlorine gas, which immediately
attacks the respiratory system
of the person who inhales it.
And they essentially
choke to death
within seconds or minutes.
They also used phosgene
gas because this did not
stimulate that choking.
And in some ways
it could infiltrate
the respiratory
system even more.
It had a delayed effect.
So it would linger around.
And you have the
use of mustard gas.
Mustard gas was very
hard to protect against.
It wouldn't immediately
have you choke to death
like chlorine gas.
It would be severe blistering.
It would essentially take
you out of the battle.
It was very hard
to protect against.
And it would also linger
around in the trench.
So it made the trench a very
toxic environment to work in.
So these are very,
very, very ugly weapons.
I mean, war itself is ugly.
Weapons themselves are ugly.
I mean, the machine gun
is not a pleasant weapon.
It can mow people down.
But even folks
who view something
like a machine gun as
an acceptable thing
tend to view these things
as particularly ugly things
to use.
Other weapons that
showed up in World War I,
we talked about this
in other videos,
but the tank started
to become a factor.
This right over here
is an American tank.
Obviously, with these treads
it can go in tough terrain.
It's heavily, heavily armored.
When you talk about this
trench type of thing,
well, if you've got
a big hulking beast,
maybe that could roll
through the barbed wire
and take some beating
and maybe eventually--
so you could imagine a tank
over here, it could eventually--
and actually the
tanks at this time
did not have these big turrets.
So they might have looked
something more like that.
But this might be
able to actually
be part of an offensive
against a trench like this.
We've talked extensively
about submarine warfare
in World War I. The Germans
especially used it, essentially
to have a chance against
the dominant British Navy.
Unrestricted U-boat warfare
was one of the primary reasons
given by the Americans
as to why they entered
the war on the side
of the entente.
These are World War
I era US submarines,
just to give an idea of
how they actually looked.
And in some ways the best
foreshadowing of what
would play a major, major,
major role in future wars
it was the bringing of heavier
than air craft into the war.
So in particular, we're
talking about airplanes.
So before this, you had stuff
like balloons and zeppelins
used for reconnaissance, used
to see where we should aim
the artillery, things like that.
But now you had the Wright
brothers only, frankly,
several years before inventing
the engine powered heavier
than air craft.
And at first the airplane, in
the beginning stages the war,
was used for reconnaissance.
But as the technology improved,
as the engines improved,
it started to be
used for bombing.
It started to actually
used for air to air combat.
And out of all of the folks
involved in air to air combat,
this gentleman right over here
is probably the most famous.
Although you might not
recognize his name.
He's been turned into a bit of a
caricature in the modern world.
But this is Manfred
von Richthofen.
And he was a pilot
for the Germans.
And he's more famously
known as the Red Baron.
And he was called the Red
Baron because he was actually
a Baron.
It is a title of nobility
in imperial Germany.
And he painted his plane red.
So this is a picture of
his plane right over here.
So if I were to color it in--
I guess this isn't quite red.
I should actually probably try
to get a more reddish color.
So maybe this is more of a red.
So this is obviously a
black and white photograph,
but maybe if I
color it in for you,
you'll get more of
the feeling of what
his plane might
have looked like.
And it was a triplane.
It had these three
wings right over here,
or three levels of wings.
So whatever, his plane was red.
That's why he was
called the Red Baron.
And he was famous for being
the most lethal pilot in all
of the war.
He has 80 confirmed kills.
He was able to down
80 enemy aircraft.
So 80 confirmed
wins, I guess you
can say in combat, which is more
than any other folks in World
War I. So very,
very famous pilot.
He himself-- when you're talking
about any of the combatants
in World War I did not have
a long life expectancy.
The pilots especially
this was a dangerous game.
And he also, despite
being the top pilot,
the top ace, amongst all
the pilots in World War I,
he also ended up getting
shot in the air in 1918.
He literally got shot through
the lungs and the heart.
He somehow managed
to land his plane.
And when the people ran up
to him, the accounts say,
that his famous last
words as he died,
right when they ran up
to him, was "kaput".
So interesting.
And on top of
that, he's now been
turned into a bit
of a caricature.
I mean, us in the
West, in the US,
we recognize the
brand Red Baron pizza.
It is named for the Red Baron,
for Manfred von Richthofen.
Kind of a strange name, I
think, for a pizza company.
I mean, he's not even Italian.
But that's, I guess,
what we know him for.
But you see, this
guy right over here
looks a lot more like
Tom Selleck than look
like the real Manfred
von Richthofen.